well as you just heard and if you saw
you know the rally in Grand Rapids was
an upbeat event the mobile report
deflated the Russian collusion hoax
which is hung over this administration
from its first days it's good news the
president's not a traitor but the news
is a disaster for the Democratic Party
Democrats were planning to ride that
conspiracy theory to victory in the
election next year they were so certain
that Trump was guilty of collusion that
they installed their party's chief
collusion monger Adam Schiff of
California as the head fundraiser for
the Democrats in Congress Schiff was
planning to spend the next 18 months
writing direct mail pieces about
espionage and the Premanand Don jr.
going to jail
Robert Muller foiled his plans but now
Schiff is back on the House Intelligence
Committee he chairs it it's one of the
most powerful positions in the US
government Intel chairmen are supposed
to be and have been traditionally among
the wisest and least partisan and most
honorable members of Congress Schiff is
none of those things he's an unbalanced
act with a weakness for conspiracy
theories there's no part of the Russia
hoax no matter how absurd he doesn't
believe and repeat wholeheartedly and
there is significant evidence of
collusion there is ample evidence and
indeed there is of collusion of people
in the Trump campaign with the Russians
I think there's plenty of evidence of
collusion or conspiracy
well another report has been tough on
people who said things like that they
look ridiculous now you might think
they'd be hiding under the bed we're
begging for forgiveness or at least not
saying anything for a couple years but
no they're still talking Adam Schiff
first among them Schiff believes in
collusion as fervently today as he ever
did it's not a factual question for him
it's a matter of faith conspiracy is
true no matter what they say he made
that point on the House floor today from
the puppet you might think it's okay
that their only disappointment after
that meeting was that the dirt they
received on Hillary Clinton wasn't
better you might think that's okay I
think it's immoral I think it's
unethical
I think it's unpatriotic and yes I think
it's corrupt and evidence of collusion
immoral and ethical and patriotic shift
went on and on like this like a mental
patient screaming at cars in
intersection at one point he claimed
that Roger stones Twitter messages to
WikiLeaks amounted to proof of Russian
collusion the whole thing was bizarre
and worrying to the Intel committee
annals the most sensitive information
our government produces it's not a place
for crazy people probably not a good
idea have one at the helm and so today
every Republican member on the Intel
committee signed a letter asking shift
to resign his post he's not mentally
competent for the job that's obvious
here's Mike Conaway of Texas your
actions both past and present are
incompatible with your duty as chairman
of this committee we have no faith in
your ability to discharge your duties
and a commander consistent with your
constitutional responsibilities and urge
your immediate resignation is chairman
of the committee